welcome back gamers to another glorious
day in half-life Alex what's in here oh
nothing oh alright dude I'm getting good
at finding stuff yeah if you talk trash
where's boots where's boots oh my god
there you are hoof oh my god my precious
I thought something happened to you
you're good we're going all the way baby
we're gonna beat this game together
isn't that right kiss it alright I'm
just gonna put you down and I'm gonna
look he's acting his back support isn't
that nice oh excuse me Rick
dude nice boots those are nice bids what
are you doing you bow
I'm serious gosh dammit idiot
I'm sorry I'm sorry don't cry don't cry
all right you better not
you better not hey you can have boot you
can have put here peace peace on earth
peace on earth
I said peace on a set piece do you
understand do you understand dumb
sorry about that boot what's that now I
would never sell you for six names
obviously kind of sicko do you think I
am boot no come on dude
yeah top of the morning to ya oh hey
come on don't make me make me look if
you're not gonna put anything they taste
me can I hop up here hey here you seek
shall find
very nice is it that end that's fine I
want to make sure I find everything
because otherwise I get a million
comments talking about it isn't that
right boot just making sure
stay there baby out daddy's got to make
sure it's safe you can't touch me you
can't touch me god damn it yeah oh it's
so awkward opening doors boot gangs
you ain't got nothing you got nothing on
bow game mother come on what you got oh
shoot ah that makes no sense
yeah but gang yeah yeah yeah as I said
that right Biman yeah huh Manuel Manuel
okay I will find it there it is found it
get out here eight barrels Oh boot sorry
I ain't freakin ate both come on come on
man come on man come on man
don't be shy yeah that's right what's
your name what's your name it's [ __ ]
damn it
of course of course
yeah yeah yeah get in there get in there
get 14 porn if yeah it's called equate
poor defenseless man lady or boot this
my best friend yeah that I'm totally
really good all right come on hey wake
up wake up dude hey buddy hey buddy we
didn't make it this far to mess it up
all right this dangerous yep conquered
by the combine get them off the planet
let's hear one then another year to
mass-produce the Russell's oh just
quietly we will need to rebuild society
shut up otherwise people won't be able
to buy them ha ha ha ha so funny
sesame being unfunny for hours sorry
guys
hey boot put you there or storage or
non-smoking it's epic oh look at that oh
look at that oh they're everywhere
all right oh ok let's be careful ok
let's be careful ty Ann that oh my god
dude if Flint goes I like that
I like when they flick Oh all right
anything comes I am leading and smeeting
dude this is an big accident waiting to
happen
oh thank you but-- well spotted well
done let's make sure I'm looking around
properly I don't miss anything more like
sing lll-look you barely see this one
alright just need but-- all the way spit
him out spit them out dude Burt I'm so
sorry let's are to Felix no it's not but
what you gotta do is you get this is
what hey face off to have food look at
him hey stop complaining booth come on
what is speed
Hey stop let him go let him go it's mine
he's mine
ladies ladies you love him
ladies you love him guess what you can't
have him let that go
thank you ah gotta show choir Oh Mamma
Mia very nice okay no more shooting no
more shooting I guess I could or could I
not but we need another wheel okay how
in the world
yeah I know [ __ ] other it is funny I'm
a genius
can I shoot these no I don't see how
they should blow up those to be honest
but okay fine
gate can't go in there boot first booth
first
oh well it would be stock options
5 to 10-year vesting period obviously
the be very lucrative for your mobile
site sounds good
oh there's a guy damn high boot I'm
sorry it's okay I love you I love you do
man you're like a father to me you know
they you've been waitin my side this in
whole game this whole game this entire
time
oh god all right so don't shoot any of
the bad stuff got it
eat the food Schmidt go poop
[Music]
yeah yeah come here
do they eat each other I don't know if
they do I don't want to miss come here
but guess not huh there's water here
maybe there's something about
electricity that we can use Oh found you
oh I guess I can just grab it
come on ah yes nice okay I have still
have one more mo right or is it in the
chamber so it doesn't matter madam or
something come on boat rook gang oh
that's bad
okay that was relatively painless
[Music]
where's my boot
where's my boot huh where's my girl
where's my little girl where's my wittle
girl huh I'm not leaving without you
don't understand
I don't know if I'm holding him yeah yes
very nice
that's what I'm talking about boots you
me forever baby forever and ever I love
me some Bootsy go on and eat you seen my
little butt Bootsy I haven't used the
purse I know that but damn that goes far
I didn't realize
eat the booty I said eat the boot they
said that was a madman for carrying a
Buddha round but they were the losers
all along if that's bad right am I gonna
die from that yeah I have to be quicker
there I guess I just have to shoot you
mmm okay where's my boat my baby my baby
I love you I love you I need you I hold
you I got you and want you but Bart stop
it stop it that was mine and you know it
let's go to him
you're disgusting ha ha missed it you
can't have either one oh you guys like
each other that's so sweet
yes I got a child
Oh
written [ __ ] yeah I forgot where
the where I need it it's up here isn't
it yeah I'll grab I grabbed a little
child later in the second excuse me
excuse me excuse me excuse me
row row row your boat gently down the
peepee if you see a crazy guy his name
is PDB all right is that there's where
the same station is all right cool so I
don't need to carry you around oh my god
what's you mean your name is a melon oh
my god you're so tiny and precious name
is don't worry you're in safe hands it's
gonna be okay
your mommy's in hell oh sorry oh no
he'll heal gang heal gang what's up
what's up yeah man what's up heel gang
mother flippin he'll gang it's exclusive
for people with heels if you ain't got
heels you can't be part of my game
you got heels yeah you're part of my
gang but Ganga to laugh for life for
laugh game is turning me crazy I'm sorry
I'm sorry I'm having fun
it's not right boot you better be here
you better be here yeah my man my man
boot gang I knew it I knew it
oh there's another one Oh what I just
hit what I just hit what I just hit what
I just hit I hit something woah did you
guys see that
shut up kiss it kiss it
hey hey hey hey you want some boot gang
check if it's safe it's safe it's safe I
don't think it's safe I don't know what
you're on about
oh he's excited there must be something
good near what's that here there must be
something if boot and he's never been
this excited about anything oh okay you
can't be part of us you don't got heels
you ain't got no heels all right let's
go I'm ready for anything all right I
can scare me dude boot gang you want
some
okay corny I know need a scout oh okay
now huh please okay okay okay got a
check everywhere got a check you
everywhere
want to upgrade my gun and ever use that
upgrade got a check yet everywhere got a
check everywhere comments getting mad if
I don't check everywhere
singing Whitney build got a check
everywhere got a check everywhere I got
a check everywhere oh right a check
every way ain't got a chance I'll put
you down boot hey that's not what I
wanted to do was it alright give me a
towel
caught it caught it like I caught your
mom with a harpoon because she fat get
it ha ha
excuse me oh I don't think I have enough
I don't think I have enough
I forgot how I saw these
you got to find a way that they all
connect isn't it
there it is nice god damn I'm gonna
puzzles
it's almost like I'm a puzzle God huh so
gone I'll put my shouting laser sight
okay
yes I will definitely get laser sight
unless I can get LASIK eye for my gun
because I think that's more useful
reflex sight ads display the highlights
tactical targets burst fire bullet
reservoir laser sight maybe I should
save up for laser sight because shotgun
doesn't really work unless you're close
range anyway I think I'm gonna save my
resin I know I'm crazy like that I don't
know I want laser sight for my gun I
think that's the most important because
like looking through doesn't really work
for me
hey we got tape dude I put you here I
put you a baby don't worry
Papa's gonna go to work all right you
know what to do don't shoot
[Music]
okay I love that joke he was like a
goddamn father to me where's the gun he
dropped the gun then he why is it so
serious
I thought for sure I killed him so I
could get his gun that was the point of
that
am i [ __ ] I think yes cool you're at
fault you're complicit boot is dead
because of you what's your name
Carol listen up Carol I know how you
feel
my best friend just died but we're all
gonna die one day aren't we Carol Oh
[Music]
Carol you think you tasted good you're a
sweet one thank you thank you [ __ ]
this is for
[Music]
ah
yeah [ __ ] all that one second naps just
one second I rise from ashes and so will
Butte
I was born in the boot you merely
adopted it
[Music]
all right [ __ ]
I love you
I love you [ __ ] damn she takes good a
our supply crate nice
[ __ ] hell yeah hell yeah hell yeah
that's how it's done isn't that right
mr. pants isn't that right mr. pants mr.
I wear pants mr. fancy pants all right
all right where it's very sit here all
right is here give me some more baby
yeah give me some more of that that's
quality that's quality all right
is the control station override nearby
I'm making it harder for myself aren't I
I need all I need bow for them
understand oh I see sorry it can't come
from there so that means this has to go
okay so this one has to go like that
right yeah so that means this one has to
go like that which means this one has to
go like that which I mean that one has
to go like that which means this one has
to go like that and that big rain right
there baby
alright I'll be able to stop the train
right here you sure you can do that
absolutely
then you need to be fine
god I miss him it's not fair anyone you
love can just be gone like that thought
you were dead
they said it on the news they said you
were dead
Oh God I'm really bad at these ones
mmm maybe not so they're getting smarter
you so I'm so proud of it
thank you finally someone says it
finally all right I know that I don't
need him talking I just need food my man
he's my main you're my man don't ever
leave me again don't worry I killed all
of them I killed them all and I made
sure they suffered and I yes I did shoot
they're in them in their peepee a couple
of them just a couple just a couple come
to Papa come to ya come to Pappy I took
off my hat again so we got a new one
here right there yeah brand new I mean
like brand new you will you will you
will don't do I might go my cometh
coming
you're really shoved in there and you
goddamn it ain't completely useless oh
yeah we were looking for a battery I
forgot is there one in here maybe here
yeah
yep that's what I wanted to do Hey
all right I'll use this decoy usual
product protocol nice we gonna be all
right yeah will it be all right come at
me [ __ ] come at me it's just me and
booth what can we possibly do straight
don't touch him
don't ever touch him oh my god are you
okay it's okay
I had the battery I knew it
Oh shotgun is better against these guys
is it a line yep come on come on boo
hit him not me hit him not me idiot Oh
God
don't hurt boot don't don't touch him
don't touch him oh my god just jump
how come are you serious
damn they're tricky to kill now dammit
I'm sorry okay
I'm sorry there was only one person in
my life I could use right now but there
you are no smoke Oh Paco alright I will
meet you again in another life you
understand in another life who's who's
speaking oh I forgot to check those yeah
we're gonna be alright
yeah we be alright alright that's not
the battery then like damn us that's not
a word
I assume we need this after yeah isn't
it funny when you solve a puzzle before
I prefer the old Alex the voice actor
I'm not gonna lie I'm not gonna sit and
lie to you
she's not bad of course oh I'm lagging
what's happening oh my god my camera
keeps I don't know why it's never done
that before but today it's just like
this is acting strange and I don't
understand why I thought the point of
these was that I had to align there
there you go god they're so gross
absolutely horrendous
they really made the game a lot grosser
yeah it's a word look it up how you guys
doing in there how are we feeling today
yeah what is happening there such unique
cool design so besides fit it backing
all right well old fashioned way the
classic huh like classic you take a : n
you alright I guess I need both hands
Oh
did I do that
tip
Oh
it was it was a boot I swear to you it
was a boot I saw it okay okay what do we
got here
conveniently-placed huh
Jesus Mises okay whoo that is oh girl
you sexy you look at now that you seen
that you're hitting that then you're
lucky [ __ ]
let's look around here first
in all the nooks and Canaries
[Music]
alright it looks like there's nothing
50,000 people used to live here now it's
a ghost cars are awesome I mean
it's not there Alex yeah yeah okay so
okay I'm gonna reach out and pull you up
it's gonna be okay you ready give me
your hand come on I cannot reach that
far buddy if only we had a boot or
something man he's in shirt it's fine
oh look at that
nice well done well done you see that
[Music]
very fair I'll jump
we gotta steal it before they do so
what's the plan where's the boat dad
where's the boat yeah you've said the in
yes look to the start got it great
do I jump or do you jump who jumps lame
how can you love someone like that
very nice doing good gamers we're doing
good I feel proud to be a gamer uh-huh
and I pulled that [ __ ] and I make that
wish go bang bang bang bang am i am i
that [ __ ] excuse me yeah that's what
I thought yeah that's what I thought I'm
not that dumb I knew that I knew that of
course of course thank you thank you
very much yes there was only someone to
keep me company in these dark times huh
if there was only
come on I thought I would be rewarded
for doing that
guess not hey at least I looked right
it looks like it's okay okay sorry
hello okay you're under a lot of
pressure here wow so much pressure in
fact when i well i hesitate to even
bring it up but I did notice that when
you reached out for your father's hand
head he actually grabbed it his grip
would have crushed all the delicate
sensors in the Russell's understandable
in this case great except that I have a
hard time imagining another situation
where this feels very buyer shocky come
on Mitch
these are my Golub spine bent than them
right
alright that's locked ah not vodka it's
good it's very good
[Music]
what it's just so by Rocky Oh can't do
that oh well it was worth it
I'm here now and I'm here forgot I could
do that made it made it cuz I'm a gamer
MIDI cuz I might get me maybe a bit up
don't shoot I'm innocent
a Swedish I don't taste good oh yeah you
don't shoot you eat you don't mess
[ __ ]
yeah come to Papa
whoo I don't want to bend over
ah my Swedish bone you don't like that
hmm a bit too tall for this one I'll go
around
ah come on who ate all the shot clicked
come on man gosh it sucks to be so tall
because it Masek so hard
get that [ __ ] I get them get out of
here ah nice I was looking for they
hello peer deep I know I don't know I
don't subscribe
so we can use it here but this needs the
blue one so I guess we'll get the blue
one in the orange one god damn my brain
is large I know you better open more
doors but they leave you there don't do
that I hurt my back god I don't like
these I think he's awesome
hey that was nasty sorry about your
friend bruh Carla oh that say sir this
is work dude are you gonna do something
don't [ __ ] toss things at me don't do
that don't do that do not do that
alright you understand my guy huh damn
you ugly ugly but you rich so it's okay
I am press button
yeah that's a tomorrow oh that's nice
alright we're going down we're going up
all right I have a feeling I have a
feeling we're gonna have some fun mr.
chair I too have it to carry I'm sorry
buddy I thought their flashlights turned
on automatically Oh
wherever you are I'm afraid I'm in not
afraid oh oh there's something in the
ceiling
they're in the walls that's cool damn it
feels good to be a gangster it's a tough
laugh it's a tough life that we're
living mr. staple hair ah it's me mrs.
tape on your to Annoying [ __ ]
where my [ __ ] huh my drugs
[Music]
more than shoot me mmm please open I
don't want to bend over I got a little
bear like a little [ __ ]
I don't wanna bend over like I will
which I rock up window [ __ ] I smoking
this [ __ ] like a widow [ __ ] grab that
blue key car come on
got it Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam let me guess
ceiling [ __ ] knew it no [ __ ] no
yeah running high pockets that's for mr.
boo put it in your mother flippin home
oh my god
we got any new bones huh
we got any new bones cuz I got the blue
key card ya gotta have the blue key card
hello I got the blue key card yeah I got
the blue key card [ __ ] mr. president no
I will not [ __ ] your wife sorry I know I
said that okay all right we have done
these in a long time
oh it's delicate like flower but easy
like a bleach
press to arm grenade oh god I got so
many amazing why what is she seeing a
total waste we have a ton of them how
that's amazing that's so cool I throw
like a man yes I do
yes I do I have ascended I have ascended
in my man my man my broski my whole
scheme alright I got a punch through
these
yeah no all right who wants some catch
[ __ ]
yeah that's funny
leave some time please it'd be a shame
if you all died a horrible death that
suck that'd be terrible
Hey he was like father if it's good in
the air Oh
una out Oh see Parfum or
[Music]
now are you kidding me you're my last
hope I'll name you mr. boots come on man
come on man come on man that's what I'm
talking about you're the man man you're
the man
yeah lost my hand there for a minute
Oh tricky tricky
come out you're gonna have to come out
you've been in there playing Animal
Crossing for days now you have a problem
I'm gonna cut don't you dare lock the
door on me young man oh you're gonna be
you're gonna pay greatly for this crime
[Music]
pick up the phone David pick up the
phone all right found it yes yes all
right that's bloody all right so it goes
up there okay no not my hat I look good
right I look good right stop
have we been in here I don't think we've
been here I don't think we've been here
no no no found some more [ __ ] Oh No ayee
is it worth it is it worth it it's it
worth it
it ain't worth it don't put a [ __ ]
drawer there about is that why don't
they they may well get and the banging
man maybe I could just blow it up maybe
that's what I'm supposed to do
all right this might be a big mistake
oh I get it I got it I got it I got it I
got it I got it I got you I got you
one final warning turn up animal
crossing now Oh [ __ ] ass sick
and cook sucking my new [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] yeah see them what does that do
huh turnoff fortnight
thank you thanks [ __ ] oh my god this is
a boss is he shooting me help I come out
I give up
it's safe
Yatta Yatta Yatta Yatta very well what
the hell me what the hell man how do I
get in there man
hello hello anybody know oh my god
what's your name
steena Oh Stan there they okay the scab
lebra taking apart all right then let's
get me bro
why do that I'll just get me wrong
I'll just get me bro living in a new
label snapped I sing what god damn
that's a big guys
I swear I had a grenade
Swedish style
Oh terrible girl that'll do that'll do
that's so cool
what oh my god Stan that you're crying
don't worry
hey hey hey hey it's okay it's okay
everything's gonna be fine
everything's gonna be fine that's right
you're way better that's right what is
wrong with me Hey look my camera stopped
working I don't know why it does that
I'll have to look into it I think it
might be my GPU
[Music]
hopefully watching me is not as
important as the game itself careful
careful
yeah that's what I'm talking about
what do we got sugar two of them I'm so
lucky three of them wow I'm so lucky she
said no she said no oh no no no no no no
a lot of Nate's here bye hey you can't
do that
surprise [ __ ] I wish you could
store them
right here
well we got plenty of ammo plant a plant
eats mine a penny
[Music]
hey hey it's okay it's okay it's okay
don't worry felix is here felix is here
that day Felix don't worry I'm not gonna
pull it I'm not gonna pull it I'm not
gonna pull it oh my god oh that's crazy
I can't I can't believe I can't believe
it this happened
this makes me so sad
Jesus
catchy
Jake's exploits
[Music]
stop it
then I
[Music]
I don't want them this call
that's creepy I don't like this place
very much no I do not know that's
thought that's where we're supposed to
go oh my god what are the odds let me
just check here first
yeah damn it feels good to be a gangsta
Hey look heroin oh don't do drugs kids
oh sure them
but a bang the Northern Star we're
coming yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh
oh another star you look beautiful
yeah I got it I have no no support of
God yeah thank you thank you yes it is
Oh
thank you for reiterating that's some
sort of combine substation they usually
generate power where's your head look at
that perfectly for a giant fault oh this
might be a good field of view test okay
so now his head is properly aligned is
it for you guys huh cool because I think
you guys looked through one of my eyes
that's kind of creepy to say but it's
true hey hey girl
you don't go for write wish I was not
playing as a female such a psycho when I
play ow
I start
oh come on you can't break calling this
find your way into that hotel and get up
to the substation it's fun when the
comet picks up a bit I enjoy it a lot
wish it was more it doesn't seem like
they're for that focus on it
[Music]
that substation must be what's keeping
it in the air we need to get up there
where's where's Boone huh where is he
huh huh where is he huh where is he huh
you seen boot you seen pudding you seem
blue seen it don't do kids drugs Oh
I'm just gonna do this
come on me maybe maybe when it loads he
does that could that be it no we're fine
how long have I been recording I had no
idea I'm so out of it to Northern Star
you dead right boot mr. boot is that you
boots on oh my god
looks like we're taking the stairs dude
I love this place goodbye what's your
name
dead that's what your name is I felt bad
[ __ ] them I'm so pathetic beta
ah nice place [ __ ]
ah come on are you Kim are you all right
cool
awesome finally something good huh oh
she still work what do we got in a cash
register
[ __ ] poor huh [ __ ] poor
ooh breaker boxes let's go back to the
elevator plan yeah you like these Alex
here we go here we go here we go
excuse me excuse me so this is huh
[Music]
excuse me thought I did it lovely lights
power done your power done I guess I
can't get both huh all right let's see
what happens
[Music]
I thought I need a voltage there but I
guess we need it to go here let's check
the elevator nice
ed of it no Demuth's let's go first try
are you serious Oh
oh my god guys you know this all looks
good maybe we missed something out by
the elevator
all right if you say so we missed
something by the other Vater we miss
this obviously you're so freaking dumb
my god my god you're so freaking dumb we
got the last and they nicely might BP
goes oh my DP go wow I reach you like
that and you go she Bella [ __ ] believe I
do Skiba D by Papa do people ski believe
I pop it bad I pressed the elevator bug
your scuba team up up dip the pen yeah
you can count it so good oh baby yeah
[Music]
nice haha I made it
Amit it's okay so I'm gonna in the
episode that I feel like I'm going crazy
I'm gonna lose it if I don't keep
playing so I'm gonna save it there if
you enjoyed you know what to do
smash like and all that stuff thanks for
watching guys